[Music]
you're seeing a replica of the Apollo
capsule because Bitcoin literally went
to the moon since we did our first film
Bitcoin the end of money as we know it
that was in 2014-15 and our film also
went ballistic it was pirated on
BitTorrent on YouTube and of course also
legally licensed on many TV channels
since then we also did another film
called cryptopia Bitcoin blockchains at
the future of the internet about the
whole industry that was evolving slowly
in 2018-19 many have requested an
updated upgraded version of the end of
money that's why we're here let's Jump
Right In and I'll be right back
[Music]
look closely what do we all have in
common
no matter what corner of the world you
live in you need food Water Shelter and
money half of every transaction involves
money in exchange for goods or services
stocks a loaf of bread illegal drugs you
gotta pay for it
we spend much of our Lives chasing money
to make a living and accomplish our
dreams
but it's also an instrument of
Destruction some might say evil driving
criminals to lie steal and even murder
the existing banking system extracts
enormous value from society and it is
parasitic in nature money is a catalyst
for the worst and the best of human
endeavor before civilization we created
currency
cure for Wars
the path to power
champion and enemy of innovation
money is so integral to our society and
our global economy that its true nature
remains a mystery to most this is the
story of money perhaps the end of money
as we know it
no matter how fat your bank account or
how thin your wallet to us it's all Cold
Hard Cash there are some who want to
kill it get rid of it burn your dollars
your Euros your Yen and transform every
penny you have into ones and zeros
digital currency entrusted to the web
and computers spread across the planet
magic internet money
is called cryptocurrency Bitcoin
invented in secret it was a gift to the
world it's not just the currency but
it's actually programmable money a
potential curse on Bankers I mean
there's nothing that the the big Banks
or politicians can do to stop it
breaking every government's grip on
money supply
what the internet did for information
Bitcoin is doing for money
could it be the new gold no you have to
really stretch your imagination to infer
what the intrinsic value of Bitcoin is
Regulators the Federal Reserve the
banking system at least understand this
is a thing that they have to take
seriously this is going to change the
economic culture Bitcoin could be a
microeconomic miracle worker and it
could be a macroeconomic wrecking ball
is Bitcoin the currency of the future
a godsend for criminals
or a recipe for financial disaster
trust your money just as it is
we have a little story to share
this documentary was originally voiced
by John Barrett of the Bitcoins and
gravy podcast so when you see me or hear
me I'm updating the script giving you
better context or fixing stuff that we
got wrong okay on with the show
once upon a time there was a big party
with everyone standing around the punch
bowl drunk
politicians credited the strong economy
to their wise decisions businesses
jumped into new profitable markets
ignoring risk in fact the experts said
there was no risk
then troubling Market data from minor
countries spooked the markets rumors
spread more bad news rattled housing
prices at the heart of the financial
World a major bank went insolvent
investors and businesses made a run on
the other Banks demanding their cash
deposits the largest financial
institutions in the center of the modern
world were frozen
assets were seized Banks foreclosed a
credit crunch threatened the entire
world economy
[Music]
and then finally the government stepped
in
the largest bank bailout ever
Swift action by the head of state had
saved the day remember that
no you don't it happened two thousand
years ago
Rome 33 A.D ground zero for the first
recorded liquidity crisis and government
bailout in history
the largest Empire the world had ever
seen was brought to its knees by a
banking disaster
Emperor Tiberius used money from the
national treasury to bail out the
country's troubled Banks and companies
history may not repeat itself but it
certainly Rhymes badly
[Music]
people in power and their money have
always been at the very center of it
the story of money is as old as
civilization itself
when we lived in small tribes keeping
track of debt was easy you owed somebody
a load of firewood a neighbor owed you a
piece of meat credits and debits were
kept in your head a mental Ledger
currency is a language that allows us to
express transactional value between
people it's a technology that's older
than the wheel it's as old as fire
when humans wanted to trade outside
their tribe or Village they needed
something everyone could agree had value
something scalable
enter commodity monies
there were many kinds but each had to
embody the same five characteristics a
commodity money is relatively scarce
easily recognizable can be cut into
smaller pieces you can substitute one
piece for another of equal value
and you can carry it around without too
much trouble
in ancient Rome it was solved the Aztecs
used cacao beans it was whale teeth on
Fiji Yak dung in Tibet shells in Africa
and China
grains metal Ivory rare stones leather
fish
if it had the five characteristics of
commodity money someone probably used it
as currency
and then you ask what value do these
currencies have
if you go into a primary school you'll
see children exchanging rubber bands and
Tamagotchi and Pokemon cards and
baseball cards and Suites and candy and
any other form of currency people invent
currency when they have no other
currency and now they're going to invent
digital currencies
but Commodities that aren't durable are
a lousy store of value a bad cacao crop
or a huge new salt Discovery can throw
your currency and economy into turmoil a
more stable system was needed about 2500
years ago the first metal coins were
minted in China
and in what is now turkey
these coins shared the same five
characteristics with commodity money but
were also very durable
in some cases coins are the only thing
left of entire civilizations
money does not originate with
governments money arises naturally as
markets begin to develop and as people
with a division of labor realize that if
I have eggs and you have a cow we may
need some medium of Exchange in order
for you to buy my eggs or for me to buy
your cow coins were an objective and
Universal unit of account and they
allowed people to buy and sell Goods
over vast regions the market economy was
born coins worked but only if people
trusted that the king or Emperor who
issued them wasn't cheating on the metal
content using coins also meant that an
authority now controlled the supply of
your currency money and political power
were inextricably linked centralized
yeah so I wish we made this point a
little bit clearer you see the main
issue here is once somebody is in
control of that money supply that
introduces the potential for corrupting
the system it doesn't matter whether
they wear a crown or a suit
minting coins in a steady and
predictable manner allowed economic
growth and stability the wushu coin in
China retained its value for 500 years
in Constantinople the solidus lasted for
700 years
but in those times coins didn't have the
the milled or this sort of milled Edge
they were flat and what used to happen
was as coins were passing from people to
people people would cut little bits off
and in fact some of the taxation that
the Kings would do would actually be
take 1 8 of the coin off
taxes built castles and financed
military campaigns expensive Hobbies
soon Royal mints were substituting
cheaper Metals for silver and gold this
is called debasement and Europe's Kings
made a habit of it the currency of
France was debased every 20 months for
200 years
if no one can trust the gold or silver
content of your coins how can you trade
with other countries
[Music]
International Merchants found a solution
they recognized that one person's debt
has value it can be traded or
transferred
when those ious came from reputable
sources they could be used as a form of
money paper money
this money was not based on hard
Commodities or metal but instead on
someone's promise to pay
Merchant families like the Medici in
15th century Florence acted as Clearing
Houses for these ious it worked like
this
an English Trader ordered a shipment of
Italian cloth from the Medici for 100
gold coins his promise to pay the Medici
was put on paper meanwhile the Medici
owed 100 gold coins to another trading
partner for delivery of wine from France
the parties didn't go to the expense of
transporting and exchanging gold coins
instead the paper was transferred
everyone agreed that the paper had value
100 gold coins but only because everyone
trusted the Medici as solvent middlemen
they had created a paper money machine
within a few Generations they Rose from
low crime to High Finance their great
wealth helped fuel the Italian
Renaissance and elevated the family to
levels of enormous political power the
power to marry into royal families and
get elected as popes
the ties binding money to power politics
and influence now ran through church and
state
[Music]
Merchants had proven that creating paper
currency could be wildly profitable
goldsmiths wanted in on the action
imagine it like this if the Goldsmith
had seen over a period of time that some
of the coins he was storing for people
were gathering dust the people who owned
them don't need them right now so what
if I go and lend them out into the
community and I charged some interest on
this loan so he starts out Landings from
these gold coins and then later he
realizes actually people don't even want
the gold coins they just want the piece
of paper it says the gold coins are in
the bank and with the Goldsmith so I can
now make a loan with these pieces of
paper
and whatever I write on a piece of paper
as long as people trust me they'll trust
the paper
and effectively the the goldsmiths and
the early day Bankers they had literally
acquired the power to print money
more and more private paper money from
merchants and Banks circulated and began
to rival the Crown's coins
the power inherent in controlling and
issuing money began slipping away from
the rulers
they couldn't tax or debase this new
kind of money but they had bigger
Ambitions than ever with trading posts
colonies and Empires that now stretched
across the globe
for centuries European countries would
take turns building massive fleets and
Waging War on each other to rule the
world
[Applause]
government wanted to take the people's
money in order to finance its Wars
that's essentially the history of money
money and warfare go together
war is expensive one year's income taxes
simply Aren't Enough kings and queens
had to borrow money against future taxes
they needed a groundbreaking Financial
Innovation government bonds the loans
came from Rich Merchant families and
goldsmiths who by now had become
powerful financiers and bankers
sovereign debt and deficit spending had
been born
[Music]
in 1694 the bank of England was
established to fund a war against France
England's Central Bank was privately
owned and granted the Monopoly to issue
banknotes paper that could be redeemed
for an equal amount of gold from the
government coffers
the Central Bank soon also managed the
entire debt of the crown
money has been a tool of sovereignty for
centuries being able to issue currency
gave you the power but it also gave the
value to that monetary Supply by backing
it with a force of state with
essentially the data state
[Music]
when the U.S won independence from
Britain the first article of the new
constitution gave congress the exclusive
right to coin money
this currency's value was tied to gold
in government vaults from 1781 until the
Panic of 1907 the financial system of
the U.S was an economic petri dish brief
central banks State Banks private Banks
private currency government currency
depressions strong growth recessions
regular boom and bus Cycles
the long term as far as capital is
concerned people want predictability
people want stability
from the back of that they can plan
there's very hard to plan in the long
term with such a level of volatility
in 1913 bankers and politicians decided
that it was in the country's best
interest and theirs to have a permanent
Central Bank
they created the Federal Reserve among
its jobs expand or contract the supply
of a single National currency the
Federal Reserve Note the dollar was tied
to gold and strategic control of it
would avoid Booms that lead to busts
at least that was the plan
then came 1929
the Great Depression would have a
profound effect on monetary policy
worldwide
I shall ask the Congress for the one
remaining instrument to meet the crisis
one
executive power
soon the FED had printed nearly all the
money it legally could to pump life back
into the economy it needed gold to fire
up the mint
so in 1933 President Roosevelt issued a
controversial executive order
forcing all U.S citizens to sell their
gold to the Federal Reserve at a fixed
price
or go to prison
after World War II America became the
global superpower and visit the US
dollar emerged as the most important
Reserve currency in the world
[Music]
other countries pegged their currency to
the dollar which could still be redeemed
for gold in fact the U.S owned more than
half of the world's gold reserves
in the next few decades more dollars
flowed to foreign countries governments
began debasing their coins with cheaper
metals and printing more of their own
currency than they had in Gold the bond
between precious metals and paper
currency was cracking
this is a 1966 50 cent piece it was the
last coin in regular circulation in
Australia to contain silver and it
contains 80 silver so in 1966 this was
50 cents nowadays it's eight dollars
roughly in silver Alone by 1966 foreign
Nations had had enough of the U.S
collecting gold and printing cash
and they had more value in dollars than
the US had bullion in its vaults they
demanded gold in return for their paper
dollars
arguments about the value of the dollar
versus their currency ensued
in 1971 President Nixon settled the
matter he severed United States currency
from the gold standard
I have directed secretary Connolly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar in the gold or other
Reserve assets except in amounts and
conditions determined to be in the
interest of monetary stability and in
the best interest of the United States
never again could anyone legally demand
U.S government gold in exchange for
paper dollars
For Better or Worse the dollar was now
backed solely by the full faith and
credit of the United States government
the wealthiest Nation the world had ever
known would bet its future on a single
word trust
1971 really was a watershed moment when
the world's Reserve currency and with it
most of the world lost its tether to
Gold that was a really big deal people
have this mythology of money that is
based on very little fact and one of the
nice things about Bitcoin is that it
forces people to start to ask questions
about the fundamentals of money
Bitcoin is an attempt to adopt the
advanced computerized system that we
have the internet to resurrecting what
money used to be all about
[Music]
I think our dollar policies our monetary
policies our fiscal policies have
absolutely created a nation of debtors
not just personal debt not just
corporate debt but government debt I
mean you have to look at those all
together as one big thing what is the
wealth of the nation well the wealth of
the nation is a gigantic whole of money
that we owe to the rest of the world
that is never going to be paid back
today the United States pays more than
400 billion dollars in interest to its
creditors every year hold on hold on
sorry for interrupting again John that
was back in 2015 when the total debt of
the United States government was around
18 trillion dollars today it's more like
29 trillion dollars and growing by the
day
let's just hope interest rates stay low
when a government spends more money than
it collects in taxes it simply borrows
more or it creates more
at one time every piece of paper money
was backed by gold remember for every
twenty dollar bill there was twenty
dollars worth of gold in a government
vault
not anymore
today governments create currency by
first creating bonds or treasury bills
these bonds are sold in the market
generating funds for the government that
issued them
large Banks buy U.S bonds to flip them
selling them to the Federal Reserve at a
profit this is the magic money machine
you see the FED is America's Central
Bank but it doesn't have any money
no cash on its balance sheets
when a bank buys a bond and takes it to
the Federal Reserve the FED simply says
Thank you Mr Banker here's the principal
and some profit
new money isn't exchanged it simply
appears on the bank's accounts Magic
[Music]
fed also sets the bar for how much
interest you pay for a car home or
business loan the Federal Reserve has
been given the impossible task of trying
to run the credit and monetary system as
though we are the Soviet Union it's the
central planner for the for the key
aspect of capitalism which is how money
and credit is allocated
the Federal Reserve on balance does not
help the economy on balance it hurts the
economy and it's bound to make mistakes
even with the best of intentions the FED
is also supposed to boost employment
with low interest rates encouraging
people and businesses to buy more goods
and services
governments getting involved in money
is a good thing and it's also a bad
thing it's a good thing because money is
the arteries of the economy the blood
supply of the economy markets are
subject to bouts of euphoria and despair
and it makes sense for governments to
back currency and manipulate it moving
the money supply up and down is the most
powerful way to sedate that boom and
bust cycle manipulating the supply of
money has short-term and long-term
consequences
yeah
[Music]
central banks aim to create new money
carefully strategically and very very
slowly
releasing more money into the economy
causes prices to rise ideally by two
percent every year that's supposed to
Foster economic growth
but two percent inflation means the
buying power of one cash dollar in your
pocket today will be 98 cents next year
and less nearly every year to come
so what does that mean
if you earned a dollar in 1913 you could
buy 16 loaves of bread
today a dollar barely buys you one
[Music]
okay time for another update
the official statistics say it's about a
dollar fifty these days but that depends
on where you live where you shop and
which numbers you trust
that's not a quaint notion of how cheap
things used to be it's proof that the
value of your cash is slowly withering
away
that one dollar invested at two percent
in 1913 would now be worth
7.24 cents more than 600 percent return
versus a near total loss
the US dollar has gone from being worth
one dollar to now being worth about four
cents uh so that's you know 96 of its
original value and it's a direct result
of government control
well these numbers would look way worse
now with all these new trillions
floating in the system you see the
officials will deny that inflation is
happening and then maybe they will fudge
the numbers then they will say it's just
temporary But ultimately what it means
is that the money in your bank account
is worth a little bit less every single
day and the thing is we haven't even
gotten to the crazy part of our
financial system
governments don't create money from thin
air all alone you play a key role in the
magic money machine
it's not really the central banks are
the problem and they're part of the
problem but the real problem is that
we've given the power to create money to
the same banks that cause the financial
crisis
we put our paychecks and savings into a
bank account and draw from it as we need
it the banks are custodians of our money
right wrong
it is now the property of the bank on
their balance sheets they can do just
about anything they want with it for
example create new money here's how your
bank account shows one hundred dollars
but the bank only holds three and Loans
97 to Bob to buy something
in the bank's computers you still have
one hundred dollars in your account but
Bob now has ninety seven dollars of new
virtual money in his account just digits
on a computer screen there's no cash no
gold or anything else backing up the new
numbers in Bob's account just his
promise to pay it back
this is new money created as debt
when those ninety seven dollars are
spent say in a shop the shop owner
deposits into another bank and it is
Lent out again and again and again and
each of these people have numbers in
their accounts showing that they own
this money
so your original one hundred dollars has
multiplied now there are over three
thousand three hundred dollars in the
system this process of loaning out far
more money than a bank actually has as
cash on hand is called fractional
Reserve banking
in the UK 97 of the money that exists is
just numbers in the computer system and
those numbers are created by the Banks
Banks earn Untold billions in interest
every year by creating and lending
virtual money what's more Banks don't
even need your deposit to create new
money if they consider someone credit
worthy for a loan they can put new magic
money into his or her account and start
charging interest
so reporters talk about Bitcoin as
though it's a as though it's the first
digital currency
but actually we use digital currency
every time you make a transaction
through internet banking or through your
your bank card it actually it's not even
just digital currency it's digital
currency that is created by the Banks
essentially have nothing
in other words all new money is debt in
paychecks bank accounts
401ks that loan to Bob credit card debt
your home loan All Began life as virtual
money created by the Banks the entire
system is based on trust trust in the
bank's solvency trust in the debtor's
ability to repay their debt
if all Bank customers demanded just
three percent of their deposits right
now in cash
this run on the banks would reveal the
truth
almost none of that paper currency you
think is in your bank account exists
it never did
this seems pretty shaky but believe it
or not as long as there's trust in the
system it actually works
and without our trust well
[Music]
selling subprime loans and betting they
will fail may not be sacred but it is
lucrative
as much as one quarter of our best and
brightest are being lured by the siren
Call of the money machine
instead of science engineering or
medicine they chose a career playing
with betting with other people's money
to get rich quick
very rich and sometimes they take
shortcuts
[Music]
they say it makes the world go round and
round my ancestors in Greece talked
about the corrupting influence of power
and nothing has changed in these three
thousand years when you give control
over massive amounts of money to a few
individuals they will take advantage of
that control
Banks today are factoring in fines and
money laundering and all the rules that
they break into their cost of doing
business JP Morgan is today coming out
and saying that Bitcoin is not a
legitimate way of doing business Banks
today are tied into a system that is
completely rigged to basically Harvest
money from the entire global economy and
pump it into the hands of very few
[Music]
the existing banking system is cozy it's
captured The Regulators it extracts
enormous value from society without
delivering anything in return and it is
parasitic in nature
the banks play a very pivotal role in an
economy you look at any successful
economy it has successful Banks there's
a very close correlation with banking
profits and the economy as a whole
in medieval Europe a banker who couldn't
repay depositors was hanged today that
same Banker would get bailed out paid
bonuses and enjoy some tax benefits too
[Music]
today's Financial innovators package
Assets in ever more complex ways slicing
dicing securitizing always using someone
else's money they sell debt transfer
risks leverage bets that's what they
call innovation
history teaches that the most
revolutionary and disruptive innovation
nearly always comes from The Fringe not
from corporate cubicles true innovators
see the world differently they see the
big picture creating new products and
entire systems that lead to new
Industries Steve jobs called them the
square cogs in round holes
it's unsurprising that new Innovations
always come from a niche group of early
adopters because it is inherently very
hard for many people to realize the
benefits of new technologies
a radical new idea is often met with
skepticism ridicule even hostility from
those who stand to lose the most from
its success case in point
the automobile
in the late 19th century Carl Benz and
others built the first cars Contraptions
that could threaten the stagecoach and
railroad Industries these self-propelled
vehicles or road trains would certainly
scare horses injure people and damage
roads cars the railroad baron said were
just too dangerous and to protect us
they used their power to pass a law in
1865. it required every automobile in
England to observe a Four mile per hour
speed limit and to be operated by a crew
of three a driver an engineer and a flag
man
this heroic flagman walked in front of
the car to warn fellow citizens of the
coming Danger
the railroad tycoons the lawmakers The
self-appointed Gatekeepers used
regulation to stifle Innovation
but they didn't invent the flagman he's
been around for a long time
foreign for centuries very few could
read books were copied by hand the
people in control political and
religious leaders wanted to keep it that
way and they greeted Johann gutenberg's
printing press with Licensing Laws
publishing bans taxes in some parts of
the world printing was a crime
punishable by death after all they were
just protecting us from dangerous ideas
before the printing press there were an
estimated thirty thousand books in all
of Europe 50 years later there were 10
million as gutenberg's invention
flourished the Dark Ages withered
progress couldn't be stopped
but the flag man never stops trying his
master set him loose on each of these
Innovations because they threatened
someone's profits someone's control
[Music]
but remember this is a story about money
what if a technological innovation
allowed anyone in the world to be their
own bank
to create a currency free from taxes and
banking fees
foreign
[Music]
forbid citizens from printing or minting
their own currency competing with or
undercutting Reliance on the U.S dollar
in 1998 Bernard Von not house decided to
test the resolve of the federal
government
the liberty dollar was available in Gold
Silver Platinum and copper it was
available in three forms both in species
in other words gold and silver in paper
as warehouse recedes and in digital form
obviously the government didn't like it
they arrested me and convicted me of
counterfeiting fraud and conspiracy and
I'm currently awaiting 22 years sentence
in federal prison
[Music]
ultimately the feds didn't lock him up
and throw away the key nordhaus got away
with six months home arrest and
probation
is that a hacker's convention in another
one there was a young hacker there who
used the Alias of Satoshi Nakamoto
and he talked to a friend of mine and he
identified the liberty dollar in me as
inspiring him to create a new currency
this is actually the only recorded
eyewitness account Second Hand of
someone meeting Satoshi in personnel and
that was in 2005 quite extraordinary but
personally I'm not even sure I believe
it and I'm not really that interested
I'm much more interested why Satoshi
created bitcoin anonymously
Bernard Von not House's arrest for
creating private money may also have
inspired bitcoin's inventor to keep a
lower profile publishing The Invention
under an alias
and Vanishing
part of me is interested to know like
who Satoshi is maybe that's part of the
Mystique of the story it's completely
irrelevant to the functioning of Bitcoin
because we have the the code to read but
it would be kind of fun to know
who is
Archimedes
Euclid
we don't know
we don't know if Euclid was one person
or multiple people and you know what it
doesn't matter euclidean geometry Works
whether I know who Euclid was or not
whether Euclid was a moral and good
person or whether he was a corrupt
plutocrat and a bastard
Science and Mathematics have essential
truth that stands alone irrespective of
its inventors and irrespective of their
motives
well Bitcoin is a system based on
mathematical truths and these
mathematical truths stand alone we can
read the source code in Bitcoin and
understand it and it will be true
whether Satoshi Nakamoto is a man a
woman a collection of individuals a
government agency or aliens from the
future you see it actually wouldn't have
worked any other way think about it
if a Silicon Valley funded starter or a
government or some Professor would have
founded it it would have never worked
because remember who the early adopters
of Bitcoin were cypherpunks crypto
anarchists Libertarians and yeah drug
dealers too so this anti-fragile nature
actually was built in from the very
start and remember this is also helpful
because a quasi-religious movement is
forming around Bitcoin the maximalist
and that's really helpful if you have an
anonymous founder with some Mystique
around it
coin is an open source software protocol
like much of the code supporting the
internet and email open source means
anyone everyone can use the Protocol no
one person or company can control it and
a change to the software is public open
and transparent
the code was first developed by Satoshi
then there were dozens now hundreds of
programmers constantly collaborating to
improve bitcoin's features and security
so what makes Bitcoin a breakthrough
it tackles an ancient human dilemma and
solves a computer science problem
any shared information or data can be
flawed corrupted
anything can be faked
how do we know that what we're receiving
can be trusted
in our traditional mindset it's very
important to know who is behind this
currency because their reputation is
significant in knowing that our funds in
the true wealth is actually safe in
finance we rely on trusted third parties
like banks credit card companies
remittance Services they keep track of
money as it moves from one account to
another and they charge us handsomely
for it we trust that their digital
ledgers of credits and debits balance
a financial system that cuts out these
middlemen could be faster cheaper and
more secure
but Bitcoin is digital music and movies
are easily pirated copied stolen how can
a digital currency retain value if
anyone can make a million copies the
answer is at the core of satoshi's
invention a Bitcoin is not a file on a
computer it's an entry in the publicly
distributed database called the
blockchain
just as the Medici kept a ledger of
credits and debits today's Banks record
each transaction as a plus and minus in
their ledgers now we call them databases
bank accounts are replaced by a digital
wallet that you alone control
bitcoin's Ledger is the blockchain a
record of every Bitcoin in existence and
every Bitcoin transaction ever made it
always balances because no Bitcoin ever
leaves it
when a Bitcoin is sent from one digital
wallet to another what they are really
sending is control over that part of the
database code that is a unique key for
the new owner as the network processes
transactions it constantly synchronizes
the one Ledger across the global Network
computer or Bitcoin miner has a complete
and identical copy
and because the blockchain is public it
cannot be controlled by any one person
or computer
owners of the Bitcoin mining computers
are rewarded with new Bitcoins for
processing transactions and keeping the
network secure
[Music]
in other words the Bitcoin Network
replaces Banks and bankers
today the combined computing power of
This Global Network is greater than the
500 biggest supercomputers combined
times ten thousand
hold on hold on hold on that fact always
fascinated me ten thousand times the top
500 supercomputers put together that's
crazy but today that number would be
closer to 5 million unbelievable
now critics have always said there's one
thing that worries them about Bitcoin it
is controlled by China because most of
the computing power is in China well
that used to be true but recently China
actually banned Bitcoin mining what
happened was that half of the network
power the hash power dropped but those
miners put the hardware back to other
countries to the US to Canada to
Kazakhstan as a result the Bitcoin
network is even stronger even more
globally distributed than it was before
now why did China ban Bitcoin and
obviously it's a risk it's a threat to a
fiat currency we understand that now but
the other is the Environmental debate
sure the Bitcoin Network consumes a lot
of energy a lot of it is fossil fuels so
the concern is correct but if you look a
little bit deeper into the statistics
and lazy journalists never do this
Bitcoin miners move to wherever the
energy is cheapest and that is in most
countries of the world already
sustainable energy that's why Bitcoin is
actually driving fossil fuels out and
increasing sustainable energy
it's almost concern trolling from the
media it's like we are very concerned
about the energy impact of Bitcoin oh
you should really check out the energy
impact of capitalism or even better the
energy impact of War do you know who the
largest consumer of energy in the United
States is
the military right and the largest
consumer of oil also and the biggest
polluter in the world is the military so
[Music]
pardon me if I don't take that concern
so seriously
central banks create money to boost the
economy and try to pull it back out
before inflation heats up but no one
knows how much Magic Money Global banks
are creating to boost their profits with
questionable loans bitcoin's completely
the opposite it's totally transparent
you know exactly how many exists the
computer code behind Bitcoin has a
built-in brake pedal cutting the
creation of Bitcoins in half every four
years
this ensures a transparent controlled
scarcity and ultimately limits the total
number of Bitcoins to 21 million
no lobbyists no politician no Banker can
create more or change the mathematical
rules dictating their creation
dancing accountability and that's
something I think is most exciting about
Bitcoin and the technology behind it is
not so much that it will supplant the
dollar or that it will supplant
government itself
but that all of a sudden there's a
competitor to government and that
government itself now needs to look over
its shoulder more than it did
in 2014 the Believers of Bitcoin thought
and dreamed about replacing the dollar
but clearly that hasn't happened and in
my view it will never happen just like
the internet gave us tweets and blogs
and ebooks but it didn't replace books
or bookstores
remember a commodity money is relatively
scarce easily recognizable can be cut
into smaller pieces you can substitute
one piece for another of equal value
and you can carry it around without too
much trouble
let's talk about these five
characteristics one more time to drive
the point home right so Bitcoin clearly
is scarce in fact some would argue it's
a scarce as financial asset in the world
right the inflation rate that Bitcoin
mining has slowed down so it gets scars
and scarcer every four years it is
divisible we can divide it by 100
billion times it's transportable I can
send it to anyone on the planet and it
doesn't matter which country you're in
the verifiability is interesting I can
verify my Bitcoin immediately in a split
second but a fake dollar bill a fake
gold coin I'm not so sure I could spot
that back to you John this digital
currency has the five key
characteristics of money but is it a
store of value
is it stable or will it diminish over
time like a commodity rendered useless
or a crop that fails
so this was really the big question of
the first seven eight years of Bitcoin
can it be a store of value Bitcoin has
been the best performing financial asset
of the last decade no doubt about it but
it has been volatile let's be honest so
how I like to think about it is short
term versus long-term volatility right
over the long run Fiat currencies lose
value by inflation every couple of years
you lose you lose to lose we've seen the
statistics Bitcoin however
increases in value over the long run but
on the short term well it can lose 10
percent maybe even 50 over a short
period of time you have to be prepared
for that
you could not miss the point more
effectively than by thinking of Bitcoin
as a currency and payment Network though
will make shopping easier for the first
world Bitcoin is about everything else
everywhere else
there are 2.5 billion people without a
bank account
a mobile phone with an internet
connection is now a bank with access to
the global Marketplace
what happens when Bitcoin services and
infrastructure and Bitcoin wallets and
payment processes start going into these
countries these people will be able to
gain benefits from trade where they
could not previously these people will
be able to send money home International
remittance which is one of the major
pain points of the current Financial
system
seven years later Stefan has become a
major voice as a Bitcoin only educator
and podcaster so good to see you after
so many years and so I'm just reflecting
back on what you said told us in 2014-15
um what's your quick take on that one
well I think to be honest I came out
pretty well from that right because I
was just basically saying it's going to
enable more and more people to transact
around the world where currently they're
not able to now could we have known back
then that the message of day-to-day
transactions all happening on chain that
didn't really pan out that said
lightning Network now has become has
grown and come to a level now where it
can be used for day-to-day Commerce
I probably could not have foreseen how
quickly nation-state adoption would have
happened obviously El Salvador being the
big example there of a country adopting
Bitcoin as legal tender which is
obviously a huge step so we were
thinking of building Bitcoin
City
this small Central American country has
even announced a new form of government
Bond it will hold half of the funds in
Bitcoins and use the other half to build
infrastructure they have also started to
mine Bitcoins with clean geothermal
energy from an actual volcano people can
potentially invest into El Salvador and
be funding the Bitcoin city project
the interesting part is it has I believe
it's a 6.25 coupon and on top of that
there will be a Bitcoin dividend also
[Music]
we actually built this world that we
live in over the last two or three
hundred years we've made some mistakes
we've learned to make things better
the idea that there's some magic key
that if you just sort of stop doing a
few things that there'll be this perfect
order that will settle is a very
childish ideological delusion in my
opinion but that is not to say that
Bitcoin is an exciting thing it's a
terrifically exciting thing
but we have to try and engage with it
with working Minds not with magical
thinking people are suggesting that it's
going to be another world currency
arriving in the dollar or the Euro or
the Yen I think that's
not going to happen
I prefer to trust the banks or the
central government compared to the
Bitcoin is because someone's accountable
whereas with the Bitcoin it's completely
deregulated
there's no central control
there's no one held accountable
it is a free float it's purely demand
and Supply driven
so clearly this is not a currency
currencies don't behave like this but
what this is is a high risk speculative
commodity
so for the entrepreneurs the bankers the
governments and everyone else studying
and watching Bitcoin all I have to say
is that there will probably be a lot of
volatility and upward trajectory and to
buckle up
oh boy
so what's your first reaction to this oh
my God I feel like I look like a child
um it's been uh seven years I think
since I said that we actually just
celebrated our 10th year anniversary so
for any company that's a really big
milestone in cryptocurrency world that
makes us uh the ogs and uh kind of an
original firm
um so we have a lot of things to
celebrate
so not only have we survived and helped
build this economy up but the things I'm
most proud of is that our users have
performed over a trillion dollars worth
of on-chain transactions we've had over
80 million people test and use
blockchain.com Wallets on iOS Android
and web and really built out a robust
business
[Music]
we've also built out a full
institutional offering though so now we
do custody we do lending we have a
venture fund and we're also working with
protocol projects to do all kinds of new
exciting things like get distribution
into the retail base and much more so uh
we're starting to look a little bit more
ironically like a JP Morgan in some ways
but with the intent of building out a
crypto Services firm for the next 10
years and the digitization of financial
services has blended with crypto and now
it is going to run rampant through all
these institutions and without a doubt
not only are they going to start
offering crypto you know services to all
their clients but every single financial
service provider will have to have a
crypto offering or a crypto service
within the next decade
bitcoiners all over the world have
kick-started a cultural movement and the
most hardcore supporters are the
so-called maximalists on social media
you've probably seen their laser eyes
huddle and stacking sets memes
sets stands for satoshi's or tiny
fractions of Bitcoin it's more about
this idea of reflecting and realizing
that Bitcoin is going to be the money of
the world the general idea is you want
to be accumulating SATs whether you're
mining the coins earning them or buying
them because we see this like we're
playing out this game of hyper
bitronization and so in 10 or 15 years
or we don't know when the music the
music is going to stop and when the
Music Stops you want to be holding a
chair I'm fascinated by the whole
Bitcoin maximalism like cultural
movement if you will so the origin of
the term Bitcoin Maximus was actually an
epithet it was an insult a put-down term
by vitalik essentially he was trying to
get interest drum up interest into his
altcoin for me the real competition for
Bitcoin is not against altcoins it's
actually against gold and the US dollar
the biggest Financial mistake you can
make right now is to own an amount of
Bitcoin that you cannot afford to lose
because it's super risky and you may
lose it the second biggest Financial
mistake you can make is not to own any
because
you put one percent of your net worth in
Bitcoin most people can afford to lose
one percent of their net worth and if I
am right it's gonna be more than 100 of
your network so with a non-material
exposure you change your life now what
you would spend with your on a romantic
weekend with your wife
say sorry we're not gonna do that this
weekend I'm gonna just buy Bitcoin
consider it spent it disappeared check
in seven years you I either gave you bad
advice and cost you a weekend or I want
a grandkid called juancito
[Laughter]
the digital age has fundamentally
changed the world we have embraced
digitized music for
FIT Medical Records Communications the
internet
the free exchange of information and
currency can fuel revolutions help in a
disaster
but our money is Shackled to the 20th
century
manipulated by governments and Banks
the champions of Bitcoin ask us to
imagine payments without a middleman
Investments without a broker loans
without a bank insurance without an
underwriter charity without a trustee
escrow without an agent betting without
a bookie record keeping without an
accountant Global secure nearly instant
and free is it fantasy or the future of
money and commerce
[Music]
we started this journey in the moon
capsule
will Bitcoin continue to go to the Moon
my personal theory is that no one will
compete against Bitcoin as a store of
value I think we are seeing the
beginning of the end of Fiat money we're
also seeing the birth of digital gold we
are seeing the rise of Bitcoin that's my
prediction but you might disagree let's
see and speak in seven years
thank you
I love Bitcoins I'm really into Bitcoin
well Satoshi Nakamoto that's a name I
love to say and we don't know much about
him but he came to save the day if you
don't know what a Bitcoin is Right
usually the way people describe it is uh
digital cash it's money for the internet
[Music]
I know you're going to rain gonna rain
people like oh I love my bank I'm like
really you ask a banker you know what's
two plus two he's like well I can tell
you but there's a fee
down the road it will be told about the
death of old Mount gox about Traders
trading alter coins and miners mining
doubts Bitcoin is a new technology I
like to say it's banking in life
all of the convenience
[Music]
everybody knows everybody knows you know
when I go online and I buy like I don't
know a pair of socks if I paid with a
credit card I'm just buying socks right
if I buy those socks with Bitcoin it's a
revolution
I am sticking it to the man
[Music]
there's always people who are not ready
to get into the new technology you know
like when the internet came out there
was people going nah I don't think this
is going to be popular
and then the email came out people like
nah this isn't gonna catch on and now
Bitcoin comes out people like I don't
even think I'm like aren't you sick of
being wrong
get on this train you know
[Applause]